[Music]
there's a there's a glass of water on
the table beside me someone asks how do
I know that there's a glass of water on
the table beside me and the answer that
the kind of answer that the whole
structure of Western scientific
knowledge is very deeply committed to is
something like this there's light in the
room some of the light bounces off the
glass some of the light that bounces off
the glass enters my retina that causes
certain electrical excitations in my
retina that in turn causes certain
electrical excitations in my optic nerve
that causes various chemical and
electrical changes deeper in my brain
and after some finite number of such
steps my brain is in the state that
corresponds to having the impression
that there's a glass of water sitting on
the table and needless to say it's
crucial to this story that every one of
the steps I just described occurs in
full accord with whatever the
fundamental laws of physics happen to be
good it was noticed about 80 years ago
that if one supposes that the
fundamental laws of the world are
quantum mechanics
if one supposes of the fundamental
physical laws of the world are the ones
that we get in quantum mechanics
textbooks this story that I just told
about how I know there's a glass of
water on the table radically falls apart
and and it can't fall apart we can't
imagine how else to begin to tell the
story of how I know there's a glass of
water on the table so there's a problem
there's some kind of problem at the
foundations of quantum mechanics this
problem has come to be called for
reasons that are obvious given what I've
just said the measurement problem in
quantum mechanics or the observation
problem and there has been a project
under way ever since then to imagine how
to fiddle around with the fundamental
laws of quantum mechanics in such a way
as to hang on to all of the very good
predictions that the theory makes
but so as to make it possible to tell
the story of how I know that there's
this glass on the table at the same time
now this is at the end of the day a
scientific project the fact that this
story collapses indicates that something
must be amiss with the fundamental laws
of the theory and what needs to be done
in order to correct this is an
essentially scientific job of writing
down new laws that are going to be
compatible with all of the good
predictions that quantum mechanics makes
and with the possibility of telling the
story that I just described on the other
hand the problems that we run into are
peculiarly philosophical sorts of
problems what is going to count as a
solution to this problem what is it what
what is what's the minimum that we need
in order in order to be able to tell a
story like this these are questions
questions of epistemology questions of
our the relationship of our beliefs to
the external world and so on and so
forth that philosophers have been
dealing with for a long time so
philosophers can be or people with
philosophical training or philosophical
sensitivity can be helpful here in
trying to frame very precisely what the
problem is what would count as an
adequate solution to the problem so on
and so forth that's a good example and
an example which has been very very
active over the past 25 years or so of
of a problem that comes up at what used
to be thought of as the boundary between
between physical investigation and
philosophical investigation